pas du masque obligatoire sur paris ok
je veux bien sûr les petites avenue des
petites rues on n'est pas bête on n'est
pas des moutons de panurge faut arrêter
on sait ce qu'on veut on a affaire là je
vais rentrer à saint lazare j'ai
bêtement masques dans la rue je trouve
ça inutile
c'est compréhensible mais est ce que
tout le monde utilise vraiment bien le
masque moi même je suis pas sûr du bien
l'utiliser je le touche souvent je leur
fasse forcément tous les jours comme il
faudrait le faire ou de changer tous les
4 heures quand c'est un masque
chirurgical donc je suis pas persuadé
que beaucoup de français lui glisse
vraiment comme il faut pour qu'il soit
efficace l'efficacité peut être altérée
je crois si on utilise ma de regarder
l'âge de touche donc c'est pas du tout
ce qu'il faut faire
j'ai envie je suis habitué à l'exercice
ça sera mieux quand on pourra l'enlever
bien sûr mais je crois que vraiment
arrêter de dire que c'est pas possible
que c'est difficile c'est en cours à
prendre pour parler un peu plus forte au
travail les fans la journée mais c'est
possible quand même on voit bien que
même chez le médecin il ya de
l'incertitude donc un moment s'ils sont
incohérents dans les messages qu'ils
passent je peux le comprendre
après à nous d'être responsable le port
du masque si ça peut nous protéger il y
en a qui sont contre si ça peut nous
protéger
mettons le et puis quel monde ou quoi